hi i'm ava michelle hey i'm angelica
washington hi i'm jean-luc castellanos
hi i'm griffin block hi lou geisler and
we are the cast of toggle 2
[Laughter]
and we are the cast of tall girl 2 we
are here with buzzfeed to play who's who
let's do it
who's most like their character angelica
eva
john louise
yeah
i said
yeah you and i are on the same page all
right well that's i appreciate that guys
thank you so much i mean if anyone said
luke i feel like that'd be really far
off not very swedish in real life who's
least liked their character
luke that's kind of what i just said
sorry
we'll cut that part out eva it's fine
okay cool yeah who's most likely to drop
a funny meme or tick tock in the group
chat angelica no hannah ah i was gonna
say johanna maybe oh yeah
scarecrow win an award he was
outstanding in his field
that's stupid it's funny love it
harmless who's likely to land the lead
in the school musical
oh thanks guys i've never experienced
that before i said lou because luke
sings so i feel like that would that
would happen but also angie did really
go through my mind because i love your
moves and i feel like you would rock
hamilton i would just like need to work
on my singing more but like you and luke
sing act and dance broadway i started
acting through musical theater i played
oliver and oliver wow yeah you do so
cute you roll right off the bat who is
most likely to get a standing ovation
during karaoke
i said angelica because she i thought
she did a great job she just said she
was good is karaoke for like singers who
can really sing or people
on a show because if it's just putting
on a show i'm going to say myself that's
what i'm saying like it's dope what was
your go to uh uh it was big papa
yeah mine is that's life by frank
sinatra i think that's
that was mine don't want to miss a thing
aerosmith i have three because i feel
like sometimes the first two are already
taken and you know you can only do one
song each so my first is don't stop
believing by journey
my second is no scrubs by
tlc my third is bitty bitty bum bum by
selena and i sing the whole thing in
spanish every time but she is the most
impressive karaoke i've ever seen who's
most likely to laugh in the middle of a
serious take great griffin
you definitely lost it in the middle of
some of our scenes i make myself laugh
so much more than i make other people
laugh the first movie the last um
kissing scene i think like when they
pulled out we were really just laughing
yeah cause the crate thing i think in
total about eight crates have been
smashed it's a pretty hefty crate who is
most likely to be caught snacking at
craft service
delica yeah
luke who would you say i said myself i'm
always i've been late to so many takes
because i'm at craft services i
developed a bond with the craft service
guy and he started making me like crazy
peanut butter sandwiches sometimes you
put chips in them sometimes you put
money yeah it's a great relationship
who's most likely to nail dance
choreography on the first date ava
thank you guys i appreciate that i would
hope so i've been dancing for a very
long time who is most likely to be
caught napping in their dressing room
jail
or jail griffin or jail as well yeah
i remember i used i was like hiding one
at one point in the dressing room behind
the stages and i was just like
underneath the table i'll sleep anywhere
dude i can knock out anywhere on the
first day i met jl on set we were like
talking and then i turned away to grab
some water turning back and he's asleep
so i i feel like j i'll definitely
thanks occasionally who's the most
likely to binge watch an entire netflix
series in one weekend
every single one of us i feel like we
can all relate i said all of us i think
all of us are capable of that all of us
yeah who is most likely to start a new
fashion trend yeah
luke i don't use instagram a lot but
whenever i see an ange post she's
looking flies out yeah
every single one i mean i picked ava
because she does have identified
clothing right oh thank you yes
of course
i figured that would be a trend you're
setting or developing i'm trying to um
you know i'm here i look good if you
ever need someone to you know pose
thanks luke i've said you because i feel
like you were always rocking like the
open shirt with like a blazer and a
thing and i feel like that's just gonna
come back and everyone's gonna look to
you and be like he's been doing this
i've been i've been doing this since i
was like in eighth grade and no one
knows so thank you
no everyone knows everyone notices
thank you for watching and thank you
buzzfeed for having us to play this fun
game and i think i don't want to speak
for everyone here but i think we all had
a really good time we did make sure you
guys tune in to tall girl 2 now
streaming on netflix
yay we did it thanks buzzfeed
you